- Well, do you remember
how you learned to drive?
- Well, I was trying to think about that.
And I think I was-
- Where were you living?
- in Florida,
on the "Mickey Mouse Club".
(audience clapping)
- That's right, that's right.
You were in the "Mickey Mouse Club".
- Yeah I was, with all those kids.
So, I think I would
just drive around there,
like, you know, backwoods,
like areas to set.
- This is adorable.
- Oh, oh wow.
Wowsies.
- Oh my gosh.
- Oh my word.
- Throwback Thursday.
- Pretending I can sing, which I can't.
- [Kelly] Whatever. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
- That's fake. That's fake.
False advertising.
- When you say all the kids,
were you there when, 'cause I
remember, whenever I came up,
I found out it was like
Justin, Christina, Britney,
they were all, Ryan. they were
all in that club together.
- It's true.
- I was poor.
I'm gonna be honest with you.
I only had the basic Disney channels.
- I didn't have Disney Channel either.
- Okay. I never saw it.
- I can deny. Yeah.
- And so I never, I was too poor.
But like, were y'all all in the same crew?
- Yeah, so they were the like,
the really famous kids.
- That's a lot of
massively talented
people all in one place.
- They were all very talented.
Like the Christina, and Britney,
and Ryan Gosling, and Justin,
all those kids were 12
when I was 17, so I was a little older.
I mean, you know,
I could drive.
- You we're the cool one.
- I was cool.
- Yeah.
- And then, but they were
wildly talented. Yeah.
And you know, two of my best girlfriends,
Lindsey and Ilana were on
the show with me too, and-
- That's so cool.
- they're more my age, yeah.